[Music]
in daycare Fight Club news you like it
that's that's what we need to put taike
little Fight Club we'll take care no we
were arguing no that's the both worlds
no daycare
no yeah oh this is the video time up um
submit my golden grandma I get it like
Golden Gloves golden grandma my golden
good normal box you got boxing amateur
boxing is the highest title you can now
all you think about it that that's a
reach that's not all I think about you
say it's a reach thank you that's not
what I think she got it yes it is which
is also fighting wait just so before we
started pressing record you are
literally just talking about fighting
that's all I was bullying me here that
if you don't talk about fighting will
beat you up anyone he talks about food
that's one thing bart's obsessed was
becoming an actor a mother is a mother
is suing after daycare Fight Club
footage is released I'd be pissed too
and that's my kid window if your kid
lost I'd be like I'm protesting intro
what's which parent is suing the one the
kid Ian is a speed of a beaver kid the
BT or the beater yeah or is it a ran an
audience parent BT I guess I knew it
yep because if the B turn they won't
have said [ __ ] like you already solved
the [ __ ] double standard parent because
I would have looked at my kid I was a
get your ass over here I told you
uppercuts only what the [ __ ] was that
why'd you go over the top you know he
has a tendency i've been studying that
kid all day yeah yeah the tentative
dropping his hands he has desi to cry
like a [ __ ] when you smack them in the
face
wrong with you dude you're a southpaw
dude you have an advantage
it's like throw shooter to strike him
and then get my left hook yeah
is that your left hook yeah my left hook
is also just pop by signature yourself
yeah all right so this happen in st.
Louis
these solar yeah so what this whole
thing happened back in December of 2016
oh yeah in a minute
some like I thought that's pretty later
that kind of sucks the kids like ember
that fight anymore mom
he's going on to win plenty of other
fights in two years older down it's
[ __ ] finally breaking through yeah
mom I kick people asses now you know
what the sad thing is though I know like
this is probably maybe not what a lot of
you kids grew up with but a lot of like
the older friends would make us fight
our friends but it's your friends doing
with your friends not the freaking
adults the adults like the older kids
made us fight the other kids you know
what I watch this video yesterday and it
didn't really alarm me at all because
they have Hulk gloves on Hills big
fluffy styrofoam people so I thought
they were just playing I'm like all cool
to just playing and then so I didn't get
what the outrage was let me show them
the video okay here we go dad he's with
older kids after three fights so there's
excited juggling down while the other
teacher puts vocalists on preschoolers
mother mercele cannot watch without
crying that's how she watched it and it
was on his fourth birthday the fight
begins the kids fall a teacher coach of
my hair and excitement the only person
who tries breaking it up is another
preschool that's really cleared up stop
one child from pounding the others head
into the foyer good side control do you
see that [ __ ] and it's really good
segment wrongfully stopped because her
older son texted or video she called the
director to stop him
he said that the daycare workers were
making them fight not helping them yeah
that's [ __ ] up if they set up a Fight
Club and they're making the fight that's
[ __ ] up but when I saw just a video I
didn't see it with all your anything I'm
like that's every day growing up yeah
but it's also like set up like a rig
the ring of get like surrounding them
like set up like alright and there's the
ring here that's the same I'm the one
like when we grew up you know that big
dome theme that's made out of triangles
yeah yeah there's like millions of
fights that happen in there every single
day in front of adults not organized but
not organized by it I mean the climbing
dumb thing yeah organized by adults miss
Patel's there and what is she saying is
she saying kicking like yeah that's what
your sheet a pink washi tape in your
guy's hands yeah exactly yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying like the the
action that's happening the action
that's happening to me was in crazy but
seemed a teacher jumping for joy that's
[ __ ] up but just to put in perspective
though our our our the way we were
raised was not right though oh really
yeah cuz you're like everything else was
a joke until you start again seriously
okay it's still not right cuz if I had
it my way around I wouldn't have I
wouldn't have wanted to go through those
experiences like kind of be pushed like
like cattle and then having to fight
each other yeah who is my by saying him
growing now growing up that way I would
say thank God for those whole cloves
I felt bad when the kid was crying cuz I
never cried like that like when we
fought it was because we're willingly we
knew we just knew her roughhousing it's
like kids throwing sand and [ __ ] mud
balls at each other right but you also
were a high school dropout you know you
know Nevada you gonna process emotions
properly there's so many negative
effects of it you know what I mean
I'm not saying that was the reason but
the way we grew up [ __ ] this up for like
other things how can you say this like
you're so awesome you get through his
head we had this conversation yesterday
and he was like I don't understand how
this is so weird
but I wasn't getting mad at your point I
was just like I wish I understood what
you're trying to say
what more so than David watching the
full video and seeing us all clear I
didn't see the kid cry I thought it was
just two kids it was all I'd be like
imagine like me and Ryan were like
playing tug-of-war right and then
someone goes look at the violence here
and then and then they cut it and I'm
like what the [ __ ] man Ryan wanted to
plate
it's overdramatize but if the cut later
and let's see my I go to Ryan's hands
were like upper and he's all crying
that's a off like that tug of war yeah
the tug of war is kind of like pretty
violent I mean I feel like we're so much
like on the outside of things compared
to how normal people process things
we're definitely on the outside of thing
because most people are you in a zoo and
we're looking at Bart right now I don't
think me and war machine are on the same
level
well you're also outside and there's a
spectrum of war machine so I feel like
I'm right here like I know I'm not in
the middle I might be like closer
no but there's war machine where like
he's an at pro MMA fighter that beats
his wife every [ __ ] day like I don't
think on that how many adults in this
different spectrum you can see somebody
else to go like you put me in an armbar
right that [ __ ] [ __ ] hurts but I
thought it was [ __ ] funny you know
there's not many people that would allow
you to do that to that no matter how
close you are to them you know what I
mean like for fun yeah but even if
you're into fire for fun most people
still wouldn't allow you to do that to
them no right sure I mean it's not only
I'm allowing you mean I'm not trying not
to let him do it
my first thought about this was that the
whole gloves makes it kind of funny and
that is soft its soft and he's getting
hit with fall but then see the kid on
the ground that's crazy yeah that's the
part for me so if I saw these two kids
roughhousing I'm like okay little boys
do play rough or whatever of course me
being an at all I want to step in be
like hey you guys can play wait now
you're getting too rough like turn it
down a little bit I don't want any
bloody noses or anyone getting hurt so
you can play rough just like Tony I mean
just to put it in perspective you did a
presentation on why the enemies children
should be putting the fact that he's
making stuff because they need their
tiny little hands to do the stitches
I think I've heard of a Model United
Nations it's like a mock like mock
debate theme okay and then so I was
almost is my time to shine and so
usually people are fighting and you're
assigned a country now at the fight for
class for that country and then for me
I'll also be an awesome time to troll
them so instead of fighting for child
labor I was for child labor right and I
was like Victoria's Secret laundry could
not be made any other way besides using
tiny little fingers and I got kicked out
of the and as he's presenting it he's
cracking but you're not with us because
when I see war machine I'm like get away
yeah that's good I'm happy you don't
really good any battleship that's what
you are I get so [ __ ] enraged I would
be so enraged if I saw that [ __ ] was on
its fourth birthday he was crying after
three fights I will say this though once
again but what if he wasn't crying he's
just happy as a guilty I don't care oh
so fun nope I'd be like this is not the
time or the place to be learning that
it's really sad too because then she the
mom was saying that what she took to a
different daycare but when he got there
he became the boys IBM problem child
that's [ __ ] up when you got there that
you was like come here and my new
friends gonna be me up here too just
like a [ __ ] nutty thing to say coming
from a for you yes am I gonna get put in
a fight Columbia made new friends you
think you beat the [ __ ] out of me too
cuz that's how I know friendship if you
keep [ __ ] losing your fights you
little [ __ ] I didn't know why they were
hurting me like what I mean he's for
what are you expect I don't know kids
say that's pretty articulate yeah that
sounds like a parrot
I mean in his own word sounds like a
panic squeeze an opposite story for yeah
yeah yeah I know I'm just saying they
like straight up like I would be upset
that these parents are using my kids for
their personal entertainment like the
[ __ ] do you think you are because they
are my kid one I would be really happy
that's true
you'd feel sad you'd feel some sort of
comfort cuz you're like all my kid can
defend himself not come for I'd be
really proud of them I would like did
you [ __ ] that cuz daddy what I only say
this because personally you know this
girl but her younger her younger brother
got into a fight in high school and then
he's you know he's a smart kid and
everything else and his friends recorded
him fighting and he [ __ ] this kid up
and I was supposed to go and talk to him
like yell what are you doing but I was
so happy for him like I had it like
really like focused myself alright you
got to tell him like don't do this don't
do this but all I could think was dude
he did a nice little drop step and he'll
be proud of them but then you have to
just steer him in the right direction
there goes a signal a first before I
start this conversation
where'd you learn how to do that I would
appreciate that he's on your team yeah
you know they use what the [ __ ] were you
doing are you thinking what if they were
doing this let me ask you this a moral
quandary here and I don't really have a
take on this personally it's just a
question I love quandary so what if they
were doing this exact thing and they're
putting it on and they both kids have
whole hand gloves yeah and they sold
tickets to it and all the money goes to
charity all of it the kid all of it goes
to battered children yeah if I was given
a heads up and I consent it to that then
I consented that's great yeah that's
very liberal of you thank you Oh
[Music]